wenn wir als ich angefangen habe gemüse
anzubauen jemand gesagt hätte dass es
möglich ist so zu werden an das man kaum
noch unkraut muss dann hätte ich das
wahrscheinlich nicht geglaubt aber
mittlerweile ist es tatsächlich so dass
wir in unseren gemüsegarten kaum unkraut
haben und wie das funktioniert und zwar
für eine ganz natürliche art und weise
das zeige ich euch in diesem video
die sache mit dem unkraut oder auch bei
kraut ist nämlich dass in den boden in
ihrem garten in quasi unerschöpfliches
potenzial an unkrautsamen und auch
wurzel teilchen von den wurzeln und
kräutern enthalten ist so dass egal wie
sie ihr jetzt immer neue und danach
wachsen werden das kennen ja
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch und
damit wir unkrautfrei gärtnern können
müssen wir diesen kreislauf irgendwie
durchbrechen und da kommt der kompost
ins spiel ich gehöre noch ganz viel mit
kompost das ist auch aus verschiedenen
anderen gründen die gar nichts mit
unkraut zu tun haben super cool weil das
jahr jünger ist für eure gemüsepflanzen
der ist auch nicht zu stark das heißt
dann müsst ihr euch keine sorgen machen
dass dann der salat zum beispiel nicht
in den kompost beeten wachsen kann weil
im kompost viel viel weniger nährstoffe
enthält als man zunächst denken mag aber
er enthält eben nährstoffe und das ist
auch super toll für gemüse mein gemüse
wächst einfach auch richtig toll wenn
ich das hier in den kompost bieten anbau
und kompass besteht ja aus verrotteten
pflanzenteile wie kann man auch super
gut im garten selber herstellen und wenn
man darauf achtet dass man keine
unkräuter auf den kompost gibt so dass
er nicht wieder die wurzel teilchen und
die samen von den unkräutern enthalten
sind sondern der kompass wirklich
einfach nur aus kohle strömten besteht
aus laub dass man eingesammelt hat aus
rasenschnitt von gras das noch nicht
geblüht hat dann kann man einen
wunderbaren kompost herstellen der
komplette unkrautfrei ist und keine
sorgen wenn ihr keinen kompost habt der
jetzt unkrautfrei ist oder die einfach
nicht so viel her gestellt habt oder nur
nicht so weit seit im garten und gerade
erst anfangen dann könnt ihr euch auch
komplett zu kaufen und das ist auch
überhaupt nicht teuer also wir kaufen
das einfach hier im kompostwerk das ist
da wo man auch den grünschnitt hinbringt
und da kostet ein kubikmeter 20 euro was
wirklich vertretbar ist wir kaufen die
natürlich nicht in kleinen tricks decken
weil das würde super viel müll bedeuten
und es wäre auch super teuer sondern
einfach klose da muss man vielleicht
meinen anhänger ausleihen von
irgendwelchen freuden die einen haben
mit einmal dahin fahren und sich den
vollen und dann kann man damit wunderbar
unkrautfrei gebete an der kompass
speichert auch wasser unterirdisch was
auch superpraktisch willst wo man muss
sich auch keine sorgen machen weil kommt
fast jeden gartenboden aufwertet es ist
ganz egal ob ihr den sandboden habt auf
sandböden es ist ja so dass das wasser
richtig schnell frist hat das heißt wenn
man auf den sandboden den kompass
schicht aus bringen dann sorgt man dafür
dass man den boden so verbessert dass
man viel weniger gießen muss das ist ja
auch ziemlich grün das andere extrem
werden richtig schwerer boden der hat
einen hohen ton anteil und da ist
organisches material auch super wichtig
weil das ist auch zum klumpige boden
wohl gar nicht so viel luft enthalten
ist und darf schwer zu durch wurzeln ist
für eure pflanzen und wenn man darauf
kompass aus bringt und die regenwürmer
den nach und nach mit dem sehr ton
haltigen boden vermischen dann wird er
vielmehr aufgelockert und erwärmt sich
schneller als mit dem kompass hat also
für alle bodenarten egal ob wir in dem
einen extrem leid in der mitte oder in
dem anderen extrem nur vorteile es ist
wichtig dass ihr ganz gut ausgereiften
kompost auf euren bilden verteilt der
muss richtig sinn fein krümelig sein und
nach waldboden nicht nur vor allem hat
keine groben stücke mehr enthalten egal
bei den kauft und schaut ihr euch gut an
bei den aufladen oder ob ihr selber
welchen herstellt man kann im
kompostwerk immer nachfragen ob sie den
kompost 7 so dass die kurven stücke
rausgeholt werden man kann auch den
eigenen kompost 7 um richtig schön
feinen krümeligen guten ausgereiften
kommt aus zu verwenden dann ist ja auch
nicht zu scharf für eure plan von dass
es auch so ein richtig hartnäckiges
vorurteil weil viele leute denken dass
man kompass nicht viel gemüse verwenden
kann oder immer ein arbeiten muss so
dass die gemüsepflanzen nicht verbrennen
aber keine sorge wenn der reis ist dann
wird es auf keinen fall passieren den
kommt was bringt jetzt also auf ihren
beeten aus wir haben also hier den
mutterboden und da sind die ganzen
unkrautsamen enthalten und die wurzeln
von den wurzeln und kräutern und dann
bringen wir darüber einfach eine 10 bis
15 cm dicke schicht kompost aus und
arbeiten dienen aber nicht in den boden
ein was dann passieren würde ist dass
der darunter liegende mutterboden ja
nach oben kommt und die um heute wieder
wachsen können weil sie wieder am licht
sind und dann genau an der oberfläche so
zu sagen wir wollen die darunter
begraben dann haben wir eine dünne
schicht vom boden niemand auch direkt
rein sehen kann er sie ihr müsst euch
keine sorgen machen dass sie in kompost
nicht direkt auswählen könnt das ist wie
so eine mulchschicht auf eurem
natürlichen mutterboden drauf die aber
unkrautfrei ist wenn dir aber direkt
rein sehen und rein pflanzen könnt und
dadurch werden alle unkrautsamen die ihr
in euren boden sind unterdrückt und
deswegen ist es auch total wichtig dass
man nicht um krieg weil dann würde man
ja wieder den mutterboden nach oben
schaufeln das heißt wir wollen ihnen
einfach düngen abdecken aber so dass von
unten nichts mehr hoch wachsen kann und
weil ja auf einem normalen rasen
ja auch gras wächst das ja dann nach
oben schauen würde und einfach durch
diese dünne kompostiert durchwachsen
könnte läge ich dann auf den mutterboden
erstmal noch bevor ich den kompost aus
teile eine schicht pappe papier mögen
nicht alle leute im garten verwenden
deswegen kann man auch mit milch fließt
verwenden das verortet zum beispiel aus
hagen man kann auch den die schicht
einfach komplett weglassen und bisschen
mehr kompost aus bringen dann kann man
den rasen auch unterdrücken aber wenn
jetzt auf eurem bestehenden beten die er
vielleicht schon gehabt die compass
beete anlegen wollt dann könnt ihr auch
einmal richtig gründlich hätten und dann
ist sie auch überhaupt keine pappe oder
kemmerich besorgen sondern gilt einfach
den kompost heraus darauf verteilen und
dann dafür sorgen dass man wirklich
nicht mehr um krebs darüber habe ich
auch schon mal ein video gemacht dass
wir ganz gut wenn ihr euch das noch
anschaut dass berlin die ich da oben und
in der video beschreibung und dann sorgt
die dass der kompost immer oben bleibt
damit die unkräuter unter druck bleiben
und dann habt ihr eure ruhe vor dem
letten das einzige was da noch passiert
ist dass löwenzahn blüht das ist ja
falls sie den ganzen sommer der fall und
dann kommen die kleinen schirmchen und
dann sollten sie in eurem beet und dann
wachsen die natürlich auch in dem
kompost an also das sind diese fliegende
unkräuter sind so ziemlich die einzigen
und heute mit denen ihr dann noch zu
kämpfen hat und deswegen es ist ganz
wichtig dass ihr dann im sommer darauf
achtet oder auch jetzt im frühling wenn
die pflanzen ein bisschen größer sind
hier müsst ihr darauf achten dass jürgen
bete auch richtig schön muss weil so
kann man nochmal eine schicht auf dem
kompost wäre sozusagen aus bringen so
dass die kleinen samen die angeflogen
kommen einfach nicht auf dem boden
landen sondern auch der mulchschicht wo
sie dann einfach nicht wachsen können
also die beet anlegen technik ist super
wichtig und ich habe dazu auch schon mal
ein mini kurs gefilmt den könnt ihr euch
gerne anschauen dann heißt das
gemüsegarten bootcamp da kriegt man
nicht nur mit wie man diese beete anlegt
sondern auch von anfang bis ende
sozusagen der ganzen anbau guide wenn
man noch keine ahnung vom gemüse anbauen
hat dann lernt man da wie das geht und
ich glaube dass auch die alten hasen
unter euch da richtig viele tipps
abgreifen können also schaut euch das
auf jeden fall an wenn ihr kompost beete
anlegen wollte verlinkt ist hier oben
und unten in der video beschreibung und
dann probiert das einfach mal aus selbst
wenn ihr jetzt skeptisch seid dann macht
einfach mal einen kleinen teil im garten
richtet ihn ein so dass ihr das umsetzt
was ich euch in diesem video hier
erzählt habe was sich auch in dem mini
kurs erzähle so dass ja einfach mal
ausprobieren könnt wie gut das
funktioniert und dann werdet ihr
nächstes jahr alles damit anlegen und
das ist richtig cool und das spart so
viel arbeit und das sorgt dafür dass
zwischen aussaat und ernte einfach fast
keine arbeit anfällt so dass man seinen
garten viel mehr genießen kann und dann
verlinke ich euch da drüben noch ein
video das euch interessieren könnte
ansonsten geht raus und macht die welt
ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag um 10 wieder fernes
videos